you'll walk even TV hi welcome to
another ColdFusion video our Sun is
amazing when you think about it light
from the Sun travels millions of miles
across space through our atmosphere and
to us providing warmth visual light and
vital energy for plants on this earth
imagine if we could utilize this energy
from the Sun in a meaningful significant
way this is what solar power aims to do
we've been previously taken for a ride
by bogus concepts like solar roadways
but what is the truth about solar can it
really change the world in this video
we'll take a look at the current state
of solar power it actually seems like a
solar movement is beginning let's get
straight into it firstly let's see what
we're working with what is the raw input
energy from the Sun absorbed by the
earth the total energy absorbed by the
Earth's atmosphere land and sea is
around 3.8 5euro joules per year that
sounds like gibberish right so how much
energy is that really well just one hour
of this energy exposure is more energy
than the entire world consumes in one
year or to put it another way one years
of this exposure from the Sun contains
twice as much energy than we'll ever be
gained from all the Earth's
non-renewable resources like coal oil
natural gas and mined uranium combined
so that's a lot of energy but obviously
we can only use a fraction of it taking
into account installation cloud cover
and land that's usable by humans etc we
can use about 0.4 to 13% of this raw
energy from the Sun all right so how
fast is the solar revolution happening
the growth of solar power adaptation has
actually been happening pretty fast
about 40% per year since the year 2000
for some perspective we're currently
generating over ninety seven times more
energy from solar than in 2004
although this sounds like a lot right
now total solar energy is still just
over 1% of global production but the
rate of increase is encouraging in fact
a 2014 study by the International Energy
Agency projected that solar power could
supply 27 percent of global electricity
generation by 2050 alright so I know
what some of you are thinking that's all
a load of rubbish Solar is too expensive
and only works when it's sunny so it's
useless in half the world while this
used to be true in the past couple of
years some of the common arguments
against solar are starting to fall so is
it too expensive let's take a look at
the current state of cost adjusting for
inflation the cost of a solar module per
watt was 96 dollars in the mid-1970s now
thanks to technological advancements and
economies of scale the cost is now 36
cents per watt today on the same train
of thought let's take a look at some
interesting breaking stories in relation
to the falling costs of solar from
around the world in the country of Chile
their northern grid solar panels
generated more electricity than was
consumed locally closing the price of
electricity to go down to zero while
this is great for consumers Solar
investors are losing money making it a
disaster for them the problem was caused
by too many solar developers being in
the same place with no means of
transmitting excess electricity to
another grid a similar thing happened in
Germany and their energy prices went
negative due to an overabundance of
energy from solar in addition to
traditional nuclear and coal power on a
similar thread Apple's new solar farms
are generating more energy than the
company can use so it's starting to sell
the excess energy under a new company
called Apple energy but still on the
topic of falling costs Bloomberg has
issued a report stating that the prices
of solar could soon rival traditional
coal China is leading the way in solar
cell production and could be looking at
costs as low as 8 cents per kilowatt
hour according to the chairman of trying
the world's largest solar panel
manufacturer and one last interesting
fact in relation to solar panel costs
since 2012 solar cells have been given a
Moore's Law equivalent called Swanson's
law it states that solar cell cost will
have every 10 years as global shipments
increase
all right this all sounds great but the
party for solar is over as soon as the
clouds come out well this may not be
entirely true according to this guy
anyway well on this question of our
energy bills which is the huge bullet a
huge political topic here now have we
got it wrong in terms of where we are
sourcing our energy mark my words
solar will be the single largest
producer of energy in the UK long term
and you may say well isn't it rather it
may be cloudy around here I was going to
say a benign site yes and even though
it's cloudy
you still get probably 80 to 90% of the
energy coming through the clouds it's
just that you don't have that bright
point source of a of a Sun and a way to
appreciate this perhaps is to look at
the fact that plants are essentially a
solar-powered chemical reaction and UK
is a very green country but that's not
all this year scientists have made solar
panels that produce energy from both
sunlight and rain a step in the
direction of all year-round solar energy
generation while we're on the topic of
breakthroughs let's move on a little bit
and take a look at some new solar
breakthroughs from this year alone first
we have MIT building 3d solar cells to
offer a more stable output for different
angles of the Sun they achieved anywhere
from two to twenty times the power
output of a standard flat cell this
particular 3d setup works so well
because its design was optimized by a
computer algorithm mit has also created
solar cells as thin as a soap bubble
this next breakthrough is probably my
favorite because it involves a start-up
just finding a better way to do things
Vera Scott has absorption coefficient
that is much higher than silicon cell it
can absorb all the income sunlight
in a layer that is finner than the human
hair the cells are super light flexible
don't crack like the traditional ones
and can work in artificial light as they
can be easily manufactured from readily
accessible materials production is
surprisingly cheap the printing method
chosen by olga Milankovitch is stable
and reproducible this offers the
possibility of scaling the manufacturing
process the foil will prolong the life
of batteries used in popular electronic
devices a mobile tablet or laptop will
charge even when exposed to artificial
sources of light traditional solar cells
will be replaced with technologically
advanced foils tightly attached to the
roof they may come in a wide range of
colors to match the building's design
providing the household with electric
power these guys are still getting
venture capital but it could really push
the state of the art of solar forward if
they succeed taking a quick look at
solar transport there's an autonomous
boat called Scout that will be the first
solid vehicle to cross the Atlantic and
there's also an experimental aircraft
called Solar Impulse that is currently
flying around the world only using solar
power and lastly Toyota released an
updated version of the Prius
with a solar panel roof that actually
helps power the car this time okay so
this is all great but we can't end the
video without talking about some of the
downsides what are the drawbacks of
solar the main problems for solar power
are as follows naturally on any
particular day energy demand fluctuates
and one of the problems of solar is that
it's not easy to adjust the output to
match these fluctuations for example
peak demand happens at night in a
household and this is the opposite time
to win there's peak energy input from
the Sun
battery systems like tesla powerwall
that stored the energy and released it
at a later time can help and in fact
what few people notice is that batteries
like this are now much safer better for
the environment and cheaper thanks to
the rise of electric vehicles despite
this more time is still needed to
production is large enough to make this
kind of energy storage technology
ubiquitous the second problem with solar
is that the best panels are currently
about 30 to 35 percent efficient
even though traditional coal is less
than 50 percent efficient there is still
a way to go in solar efficiency but this
should surely improve as the technology
comes along in coming years and lastly a
problem with solar is that older
electrical grids like those in the
United States and other countries would
require a great deal of capital
investments in infrastructure upgrades
to make them compatible with large-scale
solar energy okay so what's the
conclusion that we can make here while
there are some kinks still left in solar
and it's not perfect there's plenty of
smart people working on the problem and
with a global growth rate of about 40
percent year-on-year progress is being
made in addition to this governments
have a renewed sense of urgency for
solar Germany wants to be 35% solar
powered by 2020 China wants to be 20% by
2030 and the City of Sydney in Australia
wants to be a hundred percent solar
powered by 2030 and this isn't to
mention devise plans to build the
biggest and cheapest solar tower in the
world the point of this video isn't so
much a matter of every breakthrough that
you've seen here today reaching
full-scale production but the thing you
should take away and what I'm trying to
show you in this video is that these
breakthrough events are happening in a
lot of places with increasing frequency
- this only means that the forces of
industry progress in solar cells are
likely to be strong and going forward
and this is exciting and just to finish
off I think there's something
intrinsically charming about solar that
idea of gaining usable energy from the
Sun for free anyway thanks for watching
guys I hope you learnt a thing or two
feel free to give this video a thumbs up
if you liked it and subscribe if you
need to the channel this has been to
gogo you've been watching ColdFusion
cheers guys and I'll catch you again
soon for the next video have a good one
ColdFusion
it's me thinking
you